adding oil to pasta water prevents the
noodles from sticking this is definitely
not true Catherine DiIorio I'm a
formally trained chef I chained here in
Chicago at Kendall College worked at
various restaurants dodging in Chicago
and I am here to debunk the most common
myths about cooking oh we're doing this
via Skype because like many of you I am
stuck in my house as well and I know all
of you who want some tips on how to cook
well your while you're indoors and
trying to find things to do only flip
your steak once during cooking this is
absolutely not true a lot of people say
that because we're all your flavor comes
us from the Browning so people feel that
if you're flipping your steak you're not
gonna get a proper brown and then all of
that flavor but the most important thing
for a good steak is actually the
temperature of your pan you make sure
you get it really hot and you can
actually flip it multiple times so if
you flip it about every 30 seconds it's
going to not cool down on the top so it
will continue to cook you'll flip it it
will cook and then it's almost like
being cooked simultaneously on both
sides so you're actually gonna get a
faster cooking time on it and it will
consistently cook from edge to edge of
the steak adding vinegar to your cooking
water makes your hard-boiled eggs easier
to peel that's not exactly true it's
kind of a placebo effect so a few things
the age of your egg is gonna affect how
easy it is to peel so an older egg is
more alkaline that's gonna make a little
easier to peel effort after its boiled
the next thing is that's really
important is to stop that cooking right
away and submerge it in an ice bath so
nothing fancy just a bowl of water with
a bunch of ice in it nice and cold
submerging in it let the cooking stop
and then pull them out the other way you
could get the shell to not stick is
mices teaming them so what happens when
you steam the egg is the proteins from
your egg whites are gonna separate and
the membrane from the shell it's gonna
give you a little bit of space therefore
making it easy to peel when you're done
wear goggles chew gum etc all of the
myths you've heard to avoid your eyes
from getting watery when you're cutting
on
No so I guess you could wear goggles
something like you look very strange but
the reason our eyes water when we cut an
onion is there's an enzymatic reaction
and the gases come up from the onion and
that's actually what gets into our eyes
it causes them to burn and it causes
them to water so interestingly that gas
comes out because it's a defense
mechanism for the onion so little
critters underground as it's growing
don't eat it
the best way to really mitigate the the
gases coming out is to use a really
sharp knife so you use a dull knife
you're crushing the membrane of the
onion and it's gonna cause more gas to
release if you cut it really just a
really sharp knife and you slice through
it it's going to damage less of the
membranes and so less gas is going to
come up so it's gonna be a little easier
also cut the root last a lot of gas is
kind of concentrated in that area so
kind of that little hairy part at the
end so to speak always cut that off last
whipped cream flattens when you stop
with it so that's not true
it's not the whipping that will keep the
air in your cream which makes it fluffy
it's actually your temperature so again
temperature is really important if it
gets warm that's when your whipped cream
starts to flatten so the tip is before
you whip it don't only chill your cream
which obviously you want to get that as
cold as possible but I like to put my
bowl
and my whisk or whisk attachment in the
freezer get it really cold so when you
whip it then it stays cold it won't
flatten during the whipping process and
then when you're done that you can store
it in the fridge if you're going to go
to a party let's just say you make a
cake and you frost it with a cream and
there's a whipped cream element to it
you could stick it in the freezer for
about 30 minutes it will make it a
little more stable if you're for
instance taking it to a picnic or
somewhere where you're gonna be outside
it's gonna be a little warm that will
help to keep the whipped cream nice and
airy and fluffy adding oil to pasta
water prevents the noodles from sticking
this is
definitely not true as an Italian I this
is just the one thing that just really
irks me so if you put oil on your
noodles it's actually gonna make the
surface the noodles impenetrable to your
sauce so the thing that's gonna give
your noodles flavor is not gonna be able
to get in and actually flavor them or
stick to your noodles so that's kind of
not what you want right pasta is even
like in Italy the shapes of the pasta
are designed to hold certain kinds of
sauces a certain way so the last thing
you want is you know these slick noodles
where all of your sauce is coming out so
the best way to get noodles to stop from
sticking is again add your pasta to
boiling water make sure it's a full
rolling boil and then stir it every once
in a while make sure that you're
continually stirring that pasta as it's
cooking this is gonna keep it from
sticking together during the cooking
process
you can include at any time during the
cooking process
no no no no no season as you go so if
you just season at the end all you're
gonna have is kind of a superficial
seasoning there's going to be the top
layer of your food is gonna have some
flavor to it but it's not gonna have
actually penetrated your food and give
you that kind of consistent flavor
throughout and that depth and complexity
which is what you really love and so
that's why a lot of times you'll make
something at home and you'll just kind
of at the end be like oh season to taste
and just throw some salt and pepper on
it maybe some herbs and you're like why
didn't this turn out the way it tasted a
restaurant it's a simple dish but it's
because you are constantly seasoning as
you go milk makes fluffier scrambled
eggs no no no scrambled eggs it's about
temperature it's about think slow and
low so do you want low medium heat and
you want to just cook those eggs slow
and just once they start to coagulate
take a spatula and move it around so
you'll keep getting those curds if you
add milk to it the milk is gonna
separate out from the eggs as it's
cooking
you're gonna probably get rubbery
colorless diluted flavor on your actual
eggs so slow and low also before kind of
always right before your eggs seem
totally cooked so they're not runny
anymore but they seem a little wet take
them off
there is gonna be some carryover cooking
and they're gonna cook a little bit more
in that pan as you're transferring them
to your serving dish sticking a potato
in an overly salty dish will absorb the
salt and make it less salty no again no
so yes will putting a raw potato into a
overly salted soup absorb some of that
salt yes but it's also gonna absorb a
disproportionate amount of the liquid so
you don't want to do that and the first
thing you should try before anything is
try to balance out the flavors so if
it's saltier maybe just a hit of acid so
a little dash of sherry vinegar or a
little bit of a squeeze a lemon might
balance it out hit a sugar so just kind
of think what makes something a dish
taste though does that balance that
sweet and salty and spicy so just see
what it might need try that first if it
doesn't work move on so storing bread in
the fridge prevents staleness actually
storing bread in the fridge will make
your bread go stale quicker so it's
gonna pull some of that moisture out but
there are ways you can keep your bread
for a bit longer so one you can freeze
it wrap it in plastic and then freeze it
and then defrost it at room temperature
and your bread will pretty much stay
close to what it was when you bought it
now if the breads already gone stale is
there anything you can do so yes there's
a few things it's already gone stale one
just heating the bread a little bit will
actually soften it up also you can put
that bread in the fridge now when you
take it out of the fridge it's not that
it's gonna be back to its original state
but it will just keep it edible
for a little bit longer it will keep it
from going bad or going mouldy keeping a
pit in your off akkad Oh keeps
avocado for browning again no it's not
this is not accurate it will keep the
avocado underneath the pit from browning
so the Browning process happens it's an
enzymatic reaction that causes the the
flesh of the fruit to it's a brown the
best way for any full avocado is to
either swipe some lemon juice on it or
some type of acidulated water or
acidulated water is basically just water
that has some acid in it you could also
do a swipe of olive oil that will keep
it for a little while because again
that's gonna create a seal on the top
cooking with frozen vegetables doesn't
provide the same nutrients and flavor as
fresh vegetables absolutely wrong in
fact in some cases you'll find that it
is better to buy frozen vegetables
companies out there that obvious what
they specialize in
so bird's eye for instance makes a
variety of frozen vegetables and they
flesh freeze them so they're basically
frozen instantaneously right after
they're picked so that is going to keep
all the nutrients intact their flavor
and this is at their peak ripeness so
this is like the best time you can get
it the other thing is vegetables do
start to degrade in their nutrient
content over time right that's nobody's
gonna argue with that so there is quite
a time often between when it's picked
and then when it's actually shipped and
then when it's shelves into your grocery
store so you do have to remember even
thing that seems fresh has had a bit of
a life before it before it got to you
fresh tomatoes are better than canned
tomatoes to cook with one of my things
that I always have in my pantry are
canned tomatoes and the reason being is
so ok I love fresh tomatoes it's you
know late summer and you get that
beautiful garden tomato and you can
literally eat it like an apple right
that season is about this long
punched tomato takes the tomatoes they
they can them at peak ripeness so it's
at tomato season when they are the most
flavorful
then they do well you basically make
them shelf-stable so when I open that
can they actually are from exactly the
season when you would want to eat it
tomatoes so they're gonna be and the
sweetest has the most complex flavor so
everyone always wants to think fresh is
always better
fresh is great fresh is great
specifically and better for some things
canned is way better to have in your
pantry so that you can cook and have
very consistent good flavor and your
nutrients throughout the year
microwaving Rob's food of its nutrients
this is actually not true what will
cause food to lose some of its
nutritional content is actually just
heat application so whether that comes
from microwaving sauteing baking
roasting ending boiling actually if you
cook with the microwave in some
instances it will actually provide and
keep more of your nutrients intact
now the reason being there's a few
things in cooking that will cause your
nutritional content to break down it's
just a very short exposure to heat in
general so it's actually in many ways
can be argued as a healthier way to keep
your nutritional and your vegetable to
cook your vegetables I had to keep the
nutritional content intact
[Music]